こーんばんはユーチューバー偽物対策本部体調をはじめしゃちょーでスパイ振っ
twitter ユーチューバー監督の中には様々なエッセイですがあるがまぁ
そこそこ影響力のある人間には偽物のアカウントというものができてくる
私は病んでいくつかの偽物だったんともっとあってきた郊外は新たな手口の店もな買う
とかで的なそう私はじめ
実は妻にもついてます公式バンクがこのマークがあったらこの人は本物かどうかって
わかるので僕はボンディ性モードがどれだけでてもう来なかった際信じてれば誰も
引っかからないという
6月状態でございますが残念ながら前回もやったんですけども前回は僕のをどうこの
偽物のアカウントが出てきて今回
のさすがですね今回はこちらでございます
これは実際に僕が持っている中学校の卒業アルバムなんですけど前髪切り過ぎちゃって
なんかここにあげちゃってここだけちょうどはげちゃってそれが良い家で何とかしよう
と思ってマジックで黒塗りしたらどうしょうもないことになっちゃってすごい悲しく
なった卒業アルバムの写真ですこんなアイコンで誰だと思ったらはじめした超母で
ございます
今回のターゲットは僕のお母さんの偽物アカウント外した家の中です
いつも外れにお世話になっておりますフォローお願いします偽物かどうかはあなたが
見極めてください
場所初めから見て実家富山
で3つアイディア頃はめっちゃ回しや2002超えてるヘッダーもうちょっとよく
わかんないですよねこれ俺じゃないからねっ
知らないから僕のマミっぽい感じでしようと思って子供の頃の初めということを想定し
てこういうヘッダーにしたんでしょう私の読みはマチガイナイスッキツイートしてるん
だツイッターでは恥じると呼べばいいのかはじめと呼べばいいのか
始め血圧を上げすぎちゃダメ
余興の広肉皿よ早く運動したいポケモン後楽しい
さ
和美社長と鼻服所を調べします
[音楽]
完全にバカにしてくるちょっと何かなんともいえないでも僕の母チャーがつぶやきそう
な内容なんですよこれ
皆さんも分かっていると思うんですけどこの人リセものです的で今回はこんなはず社長
の母が果たしてどんな人物なのかを調査していこうと思いますで一応ね事前に dm で
ちょいやりとりはしてまして弊社よく練ってごめんではじめ twitter 始め
ました
カジノだけに
いいねツイートできるのに変身できないの私を愛してないの
挑発なのそれとも挑発のこれで何か dm のやり取りを動画にしたかったから dme
つがたくさんできる日あるおかあちゃんってちょっと悪酔いしないよってここで時間を
検討してくれました
でですね今日の夜にしようって連絡してまあまあどうやら午後8時から12時が暇ラ
スって宿に今からその偽物とちょっと会話して
見ます
入ってゆけで返事が返ってきましたさっそく見てみましょう
アーマーよまあまあこんばんは魔ってか爪にまず挨拶といきましょう
まあ基本挨拶なんでまずはコンバットいうことはちゃんと書いてるか動画で人間性を
調べていきますよまあ帰ってきたこんばんは
本当んきったねーだな本当にも多いらが本当に信じてる画像武官を出して嘘とにかあ
さんマジもお返してますね
そうよまじか
なかなかクセのあるタイプだな twitter 始めました
こっからどうせる威力ですなぁ粋屋にもってしまいますんだよ
アシメじゃねーよっ
なにせもんだな今回はいきなり攻め入りますもうこれで見た目にかどうかで相手がどん
ですあなた
ん
[拍手]
[音楽]
母親に振ったっ
バッハ
これは俺が悪い席へしっかりしてるよしてはそんな今朝まで綺麗だったな
いやまずます気になりますがどんな奴かがじゃあ私が東映など証明してきますよ
おすげえ証明できるらしいでさぁやっていうの何でもしてもせなさい
すごいなぁそういう作戦か誕生日聞いたらこんなんあったんでしょ
これはもうこれで現2寸えっと
ハゼ頃か違いますたしかもけどザッツは9月ぐらいだったり気がする
ああそうだったらね冬でもないよね完全に完全間違って何でこいつ
長崎物忘れが激しいんだよイージーまとめ方だなーって見てもなあこれで聞いてみ
ましょう
家の中で昔僕がやったことだからいちばんっは
たことは何だったでしょうかっていう
ああ
懐かしいわねぇゲーハーちゃんヅラだなぁさあこれはなかなか難しいでしょ
言えど中でグーバーレバー方に買ってたことねえかってないですよ
残念正解は家の中で火遊びしてで家ごとマジで燃えそうになったことでした
残念だったら倒産で殺されかけたけどなぁもう当てて自分結果もうか閉まっちゃってさ
せてるだけ三走側商大洗うじゃない
半兵ちゃんてねーこらー
怖いわよーっ
オレオレ詐欺て置換で a まスポックバックにしや使ってそろそろ正直になりなさい
あなたは男女人は.無加温なくをしてみましょう
この質問にどう答えるかで変わってきますよ今後が
マンタなんだから
絶対に音音とコメントプレイヤーはなかなかしぶといな
ぞジェットビック3挟むの難度ここでちょっと本家池頼み込んでいます
偽物よそうゾロ掃除機話してくるの家そんなに言われたかなそんなじゃないね
あの子の通りだ
いますこれで俺のかーちゃんアー落ちる
をきたさやっぱりさ志向が強かった一発で性別を教えてくれるらしい
2がないまでに性別だけならをしていただければ
を通さねえか
me
えっ
[音楽]